every rocket launch is different and it
takes a lot of people and safety checks
to ensure that this 5.75 million pound
rocket can safely launch into space
we had a saying it might be someone
else's job but when it comes down to it
it's your ass I'm Mike massimino a
former NASA astronaut and also a former
spacecraft Communicator or Capcom in the
mission control center today we're going
to break down what happens from eight
hours before liftoff until launch
foreign
[Music]
cryogenic fuel is being added to the
tank once you put fuel in that tank you
more or less have a bomb sitting there
it's not right next to Disney World but
it's close enough to humanity it also
results in a little burn off because
it's cryogenic fuel looks like smoke but
it's water vapor even at a low
temperature you'll still lose a little
bit but primarily they want to wait till
the last minute to make sure
everything's good to go because they
would not want that tank sitting around
loaded for a long period of time it
could get a bit dangerous astronauts
have been in quarantine preparing for
lunch when you would sleep even as
during the day you had these really dark
curtains they wanted to make it dark in
there so they tried to train your brain
or trick your brain into thinking that
night was day and day was night and it
actually worked pretty well there is
science involved there understanding how
the Circadian rhythm works or sleep
patterns work following those rules was
was effective one of the things that we
learned I think mainly from our Russian
cosmonaut colleagues was that you might
not want to go to the bathroom room the
first couple days of space they took no
chances and actually tried to clear out
their system by giving themselves an
enema practically it's not a bad idea
and so that was added to the checklist
of things to consider doing on launch
day
L minus five hours the tank is still
getting fueled and the payload systems
are being activated so the payload on
the Artemis launch is Orion which is the
spacecraft at the top of the space
launch system and the payload at the top
are in this case moonachins but will
also be people when the real day comes
a scrub is canceling the launch before
you go anywhere so for example what
happened with Artemis those were scrubs
so we've had a scrub because they had a
faulty sensor and then they had another
scrub because they couldn't fuel the the
vehicle correctly and then they had a
weather scrub because the hurricane was
headed in their Direction so we uh
didn't work out today but stand by folks
we're pretty close we're gonna look at
this again and come back as soon as we
can that's what a lawn scrub is
astronauts suit up and prepare for the
launch pad after now this is a secret so
don't tell anybody this okay the
tradition was that the chief of the
astronaut office would play a hand of
poker with the commander of the flight
and they would continue to play until
the commander of the flight lost because
you wanted to leave all your bad luck on
Earth
can you imagine out of all the
technology that we developed to go to
space this is what it comes down to you
have to lose that hand to Poker and
until that happens they keep playing
until and then you then it's safe to go
and and go out so after breakfast you go
back to your room and you start getting
ready to get dressed to go to space and
so the first thing is the diaper you
have to have the duck who's going to be
in a spacesuit and you're not going to
have easy access to a toilet especially
once again to say there is a toilet you
can use on the launch pad but once you
get inside that spaceship it's not like
oh I forgot I got no you're staying
right there so you're not going anywhere
once you're strapped in and if you need
to do something you're going to do it in
the diaper
L minus three hours NASA is still
fueling the rocket and they're also
checking out the Telemetry data which
tells them about the health of the
spaceship important for launch but also
important for when the mission is in
Orbit as well so making sure that they
can communicate with the spacecraft they
can get all the data on the health of
the systems of the spaceship that
Telemetry data is very important and
they're checking that out astronauts
disembark from the holding room say
goodbye to their families and travel to
the launch pad one of the tricks that
they play on the rookies and I was on my
first flight I was one of those is the
chief of the office will come in and say
can I have everyone's boarding pass for
the space shuttle and all the veterans
who have flown before hands on this like
piece of plastic which says you can
board the space shuttle so they hand it
to the Chief and you in like you know
like hahaha like you don't have a
boarding pass you can't go to space and
I'm like you know who you're going to
get at this point you know
L minus 50 minutes the NASA test
director holds the final briefing so
that final briefing would include things
like the weather the vehicle Health
making sure every system that's being
watched at the Kennedy Space Center and
at the Johnson Space Center Mission
Control everyone needs to agree and they
get a final briefing primarily in this
case it's the weather to make sure that
they're clear to continue with the
launch count lightning is not a good
thing to launch into they did have a
lightning strike on Apollo 12. they were
able to overcome that but you don't like
to get hit by lightning astronauts get
into the Croft and then you get inside
of the Space Shuttle you get assistance
in getting into your seat you're lying
on your back you strap yourself in you
hook up your cooling you hook up your
communication hook up your oxygen
because you need oxygen flow if you
close your visor you're going to need
oxygen flow in there for the launch you
get all that set and then you get asked
a series of questions by the technician
just in case you have an abortion
different from a scrub and a board is
like something serious is going on for
some reason it was something really
wrong with the spaceship and it might
explode or there might be toxic fumes or
a fire or something like that is going
on we need to get away from it and get
to these slide wire baskets that were up
High where the crew cabin was where the
entrance of the spacecraft was and you
would ZIP down this line kind of like an
amusement park ride and go into a net
with this and then you would open it up
and then jump out and then help each
other get into a bunker and if that
wasn't good enough if you really needed
to get out of town right outside of the
bunker was an armored personnel vehicle
which was it looked like a tank but it
didn't have any weapons on it of course
it was just to transport people but it
drove like a tank apparently I never
drove a tank but I did get to practice
driving this
L 40 minutes and holding the built-in
30-minute countdown hold Begins the
30-minute hold gives the launch Team a
chance to kind of sort everything out
they're going along the clock you know
from eight hours and moving moving
moving but this built-in hole there's a
30-minute placeholder for them to
regroup make sure everything looks good
and really narrow in on the exact time
that they'll be able to Launch
L minus 15 minutes the launch director
pulls the team to make sure everyone is
a go for launch go for launch means that
we are go that whatever systems that
flight controller is looking at that
they are go no go means nope we're not
ready to launch and so if someone speaks
up they better mean it astronauts aren't
allowed to chime in on the go no-go they
don't really ask us maybe for fear that
one of us might say no I don't want to
go and then we're like well it's too
late you're going I've never heard of
anyone on launch pad having second
thoughts it's too late by then just keep
quiet doesn't matter you're going
T minus 10 minutes final checks and
systems go for a liftoff novel check of
the srv's firing chain is armed once we
get into you know ten nine eight when
that's going on in just a few seconds
away you're like okay I guess they're
really going to do this to us
and it just keeps going and then at six
seconds on the space shuttle the main
engines with light support so now the
Beast has come to life is what it feels
like you still didn't go anywhere you
still held down explosive bolts would
hold the solid rocket boosters in place
they would explode when there was time
for the whole stack to take off you're
on your way it might not be where you
want to go but that's where you're
headed and you're at the mercy of those
things for two and a half minutes until
they leave the vehicle and then for the
final six minutes you continue to ride
the main engines the liquid-fueled
engines to orbit
once you lift off there's no doubt that
you have lifted off you accelerate
immediately before you clear the tower
you're already going 100 miles an hour
and you're accelerating from zero to 17
500 miles an hour in just eight and a
half minutes and the words that kept
going through my mind were speed and
power speed and Power
and right at about maybe the two minute
Mark leaving the planet I had this
Sensation that I was really leaving home
for the first time
foreign
there was a sense of I'm really heading
somewhere that I'd never been before far
away from home